i don't believe i've ever uh gotten the
chance to meet um our next guest chosen
out of south dakota state
second round of the 2018 nfl draft now
getting set to lead the eagles in that
run defense run offense and jalen hurts
in that passing offense into
the spot
where the defending world champs will
begin their title defense in a win or go
home game joining us here on the rich
eisen show philadelphia eagles tight end
dallas goddard how are you dallas
i'm doing good how are you i'm doing
fine so um walk me through how the
eagles are feeling right now um
as the seventh seed going into the spot
where the defending world champs reside
dallas goddard yeah uh we feel we feel
really good um you know early in the
season uh
we were kind of road warriors we're
getting all our wins on the road so uh
to be in the playoffs to go and play the
defending champions uh you know it's a
great opportunity for
the young team we have and we're really
excited looking forward to it and ready
to go down there and play a great game
of football how is this team different
from that week one team that did go on
the road won a game in atlanta i mean
how is that
how is this team different from that one
dallas goddard
um you know since week one uh just as a
team offense defense special teams we've
just grown so much
we found our identity and uh we really
embraced it um you know we we started
running the rock really fast effectively
offensively and we've been able to get
play action some shots down the field
like that and then you know our running
game has just been taking off so much
and
jalen back there uh being the explosive
quarterback that he is you know it's
been a lot of fun and we've just been
able to continue to grow uh get better
each week but grow as a you know a team
and we're really close we have a lot of
fun and we're looking to show that on
sunday yeah i mean so much has been made
dallas about the eagles um losing
touch with their run game
and then dedicating all of a sudden to
just focusing explicitly as it seemed on
that
um
was there a moment where you go into a
meeting room and it's just like okay
this is what we're gonna do and then all
of a sudden was radically different than
the couple weeks before was there a
moment like that
dallas there wasn't ever a really moment
like that uh in a meeting room or
anything like that um but when we did go
play detroit um we were able to run the
ball really effectively against then
against them and then from there on out
the rest of the season it kind of seemed
like that was more of a focus it was
nothing that was ever said um
but it was something that you could see
in the game plan that it started to
develop more and push towards that uh
bigger people on the field more tight
ends um more max protection on our
passes and stuff
so it was just kind of one thing that i
feel like when we figured out our
identity and we as a team embraced the
run game the physicalitiness of it and
all that and i think it was just oh it
was working so well you just can't go
away from it and what was it like at
that point in time when uh zach hurts
did get dealt and now it was you pretty
much the one for sure 100 it's your
position and your relationship with him
and that moment in time right around the
trade deadline this year dallas goddard
what was that about yeah for me um it
was really exciting um
being with him for my first three years
and the start of this season um you know
i was able to learn a lot from him me
and him have a great relationship
and you know like i said i learned a lot
from them but when uh detroit happened
talking to howie
it was really exciting for me obviously
um a very big step in my career to be
the guy and you know the
faith of that the organization had in me
to uh deal zach um you know just showed
me how much they respect me and think of
me so um from then on out you know i was
just going to work every day uh showing
them that they made the right decision
and your quarterback jalen hurts how has
he grown in the role dallas
you know he he's made tremendous steps
this year um just what he can do in the
pocket throwing um obviously you can't
ever take away the things he does
with his feet running the ball he's
incredible you know uh making plays
scrambling but he's just grown so much
being able to stay in the pocket step up
keep his eyes downfield and you know my
biggest thing for him is he's a winner
he's going to do anything he can
to win games and you know uh he's got
the ability to do a lot of things and
he's definitely a big part of the reason
that we are where we are and uh
walk me through uh a huddle with him
game online what he's like
uh game on the line you know it doesn't
change it doesn't matter if we're up 30
down 30. uh he's cool calm collected
composed he's in there he calls a play
and he's like you know he he's just so
confident in himself and the people
around him that you know it he never
skips a beat he never gets too high too
low he's just just steady jailing hurts
at all moments and you know that's
pretty awesome and to play with a guy
like that
it just helps the whole team stay
composed no matter what's happening yeah
even i guess when stands fall down right
like i saw that one like it didn't fit
it doesn't matter what happened he makes
plays i saw that you know the railing
comes apart the fans come spilling out
there and it it it looked like he was
expecting it it's kind of crazy he
really has no
he has no reaction that sort of thing
dallas got her here on the rich eisen
show in terms we talked about so much of
growth uh so i should ask you have you
watered and fertilized today
dallas scott oh yeah yeah we definitely
we definitely got a lot of watering in
today fertilizing okay uh you know it's
kind of the main thing keep the main
thing the main thing get better each and
every day
you know practice today it looked good
it was crisp and uh you know i think the
whole team's ready to go so we're
definitely uh going to be watered up and
fertilized
i really enjoyed that speech from uh
from coach nick ciriani was that was
that the best one he's given this year
the water and fertilizing cause you by
the way i don't know if you were aware
you you went seven and two after the
water and fertilizing after all that
yeah you know uh coach seriously had a
lot of uh
great stories to tell us and you know
every time he comes into a team meeting
it feels like the message he's protect
portraying uh just fits so much with
what we're doing what we're trying to do
but yeah that's definitely one of my
favorite ones that he said all year
the best part about it is how the media
took it and spun it and you know kind of
made him
look stupid at the moment
and then you know looking back at it
like you said we went seven and two
after that and you know the message was
really we're doing a lot of good things
the results aren't showing we're not
getting the wins yet but you know trust
the process that we have double down on
our process and the results will come
we'll we'll get there to where we want
to be and you know it just
spoken into fruition here we are and uh
first round of the playoffs ready to go
yeah man i mean it looks like you are
buying what he's selling the fertilizer
or water that he's selling it looks like
the whole team's buying it you know yeah
everybody's everybody's taking a drink
and putting and sprinkling a little on
so we can keep growing i love it let's
talk about you a little bit here um
growing up you're from north dakota
right that's where you're from
originally oh you're born in north
dakota my first three years was in north
dakota but uh the rest of the time i
went to school in south dakota okay so
uh how much you know what was your team
is that is that broncos country is that
is it vikings country what is what is
the country of the dakotas for the nfl
it's probably where i'm at the mostly uh
minnesota fans okay um i grew up a
packers fan though i was one of the kids
that liked to argue and bet against
people so
everybody was a vikings fan so i took
the packers and you know worked out that
was definitely the right decision yes
about that worked out for you i'd
imagine yeah you know i got to see great
quarterbacks for a while and
um you know it's more fun than being a
vikings fan that's for sure okay so uh
were you always a tight end like where
how did you get to that position in the
dakotas
yeah so in high school i kind of played
everything um you know i play
quarterback a little bit running back
wide receiver
defense
he played safety linebacker defensive
end kind of everything um
you know from
9 to 12 i think we only had 17 players
out so you just kind of had to play damn
whatever but
when i got recruited everybody recruited
me as a tight end even though i never
really played tight end um it was just
the coaches told me that i had the body
type for it and you know they kind of
sold me on it and i believed them and
you know kind of bought into being a
tight end and it worked out so was when
wence was there was there a dakota's
battle within the
huddle at any point or like what is that
like is there is there
when he was here it was cool to have you
know somebody that played in the fcs uh
so close
to me and we definitely
we bet every time they played uh it was
tough because i think when he was here
they won every time and
uh
then last year we finally beat them a
couple times but we didn't make the bet
because he was in indianapolis we had a
lot of good bets and uh we got to watch
a couple games together so that was fun
okay were your folks cowboys fans how
come you're named dallas
yeah my uh my dad was a big cowboys fan
he he used to love them
i got him converted to an eagles fan it
was tough but uh yeah he was a he was a
big dallas fan uh named me after the
team wanted me to be a cowboys fan but
uh i couldn't do that well now
we all see the irony right that you're
now an eagle
in the division named dallas and it is
your
mission every year to beat dallas as
many times as you possibly
can right i mean there is an irony here
right yeah uh no it's it's
it's quickly uh became one of my
favorite rivalries that i've had you
know uh hearing the dallas sucks chance
things like that it's just pretty cool
knowing that that's my name uh you know
they're not booing you or whatever but
uh just having that name and as big of a
rivalry it is it's definitely a cool
thing okay and in order to to make this
game obviously you'd already made the
playoffs but beating you know you played
dallas in the final game and that was
kind of just uh you know obviously your
team you didn't have a lot of um
starters out there now now the robbers
meet in the road now okay so
um
what do you say to those who say you
have no chance
to go down there and beat the defending
world champs with tom brady in his
building where he won the super bowl
last year dallas cotter
um you know i think we got a lot of
belief uh in this building we're not too
worried about what everybody else thinks
but uh you know we're putting all our
money on ourselves i think you know just
what we can do uh
the different people we have offensively
if we can run the ball the way we've
been running and uh just where uh the
buccaneers out i think we'll be in good
shape you know if we can get ahead and
let let our good pass rush get after tom
brady
hopefully
you know we can get a couple turnovers
and anytime that happens you can win the
turnover battle uh you can win the game
you know because the last time there was
a big uh run for the eagles in the
playoffs there were those dog masks
right like
because everyone would consider you were
underdogs is there any is any sense like
that now you got something cooked up for
this
i can't guarantee that the o-line isn't
going to do something you know with the
personalities jason kelsey and lane
they always like to embrace
whatever the media is saying
so it'll be interesting to see what they
do but you know we're just focused on uh
going down there and playing a good game
of football and coming out on top when
is kelsey talking to the team when does
he usually do that i saw that speech
last week i saw or two weeks ago when
you had a chance to
beat the washington football team
yeah anytime you get to listen to kelsey
talking
it's a true treat um obviously uh his
speech after the super bowl and then um
i get a few more because a lot of times
the coach does ask but you know he'll
probably come up and talk but before the
game you know he talked once this week
talking about the details and the little
things that win you and lose you playoff
games um but man anytime he speaks uh
you can tell it's just
the focus and the detail to everybody
listening to him is pretty incredible
just
because he is
the amazing person that he is well at
least you get to go down to tampa it's
not like zero degrees you know what i
mean like that's where the game in
buffalo if you saw about all that
because you're from the dakotas you must
know about all play playing football in
some freezing weather you know yeah i
played in a few a few games and like you
said i'd i'd much rather go to tampa and
play in warm weather than cold what do
you consider football weather what
you're playing in this weekend or the or
the freezing weather what's football or
the dallas goddard what is it uh ideal
football weather is probably like
between 50 and 60. okay you know not too
hot but not too cold uh
you know when it gets cold it's
definitely a mindset and whatever team
wants to win whatever team wants to be
the physical team has the advantage um
but when it's nice out you know you can
just go run around not get tired uh if
it's not too hot and just play your best
football did you hear the conversation
that bart scott started about what you
do when it's cold to stay warm did you
hear about that one yesterday dallas no
i didn't oh
wow this is incredible that i get to
inform you uh he says to pop the blue
pill uh viagra helps he says to keep the
body weight gets the blood flowing huh
apparently
apparently i can see it working
i don't know it might be dangerous to do
before a game with a drug test but
that's what we were hearing too
you know and then after four hours you
got to consult your doctor so
you know that might be a problem
you know during the game so that's
that's what do you do to stay warm
during a game then if not that like what
what what would you counsel those
playing in that game someone from the
dakotas
well
you know it's a lot easier to stay warm
in the nfl than it was at uh the fcs
level or in high school uh you know here
you get to have heated benches you have
a bunch of side line heaters and stuff
um and then when you're on the field you
know most of the time your adrenaline is
going so much you really only get cold
on the sideline but like i said in the
nfl with the heated benches the
uh big jet heaters or whatever they are
uh you just kind of stay warm and use
your adrenaline you mean in the fcs they
didn't bring the there you didn't bring
your own benches on the road like
everybody in the nfc east is apparently
doing now you know that doesn't happen
but not at all and we would have it uh
where it had to be
equal in the playoffs at the fcs level
in the playoffs each team had to have
the same stuff on the sideline but for
some reason every time we went on a road
game uh the heaters on our side didn't
work
you know yeah they didn't have the
batteries they didn't have the new
batteries in there i guess huh they
forgot a little bit of stuff
have a great time way smarter to bring
home
have a great time in the playoffs dallas
goddard let's talk again really
appreciate it appreciate it right back
at you that's dallas goddard everybody
ed goddard
follow him on twitter go for it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here